it was a return of the best players in
the world to the capital of chess in the
US and the competitors were out for
blood Grandmaster anish giri went
straight for the throat of the new
number two player in the world Maxine
vashi lagrave but the wily Frenchman was
able to slip the grip and make a draw to
save the game last minute replacement
Peter Spindler was holding his own
against Vasily couple of but a terrible
blunder cost a seven-time Russian
champion an entire piece giving the
former world champion an easy point and
an early position atop the leaderboard
in an important game Hikaru Nakamura the
winner of the Paris event faced off
against his countrymen Wesley so in a
battle of the co-leaders of the grand
chest or after a complicated struggle
Wesley was able to gain the upper hand
to win in the end game making him one of
only two players in a tie for first the
kings of chess will look to try to
dominate their opposition round 2 of the
fourth edition of the sink filled cup
starts right now